hello you're watching entertainment week
coming up on the show ahead of the
biggest event in the british movie
calendar we speak to the head of bafta
and we'll be giving our predictions on
who will be taking home the top gongs at
this weekend's awards queen of the
valleys ruth jones joins us to talk
about her fourth series of stella and
ardman animation's co-founders nick park
and peter lord on their silent movie
star shawn machine
first let's catch up on the week's
entertainment news there is flash
photography coming up
the nominees for this year's oscars
gathered at the academy's annual
luncheon in la including british
hopefuls eddie redmayne and rosamond
pike everything is at the moment is just
not what i expect so um hello former rap
mogul shug knight was taken to hospital
after suffering chest pain shortly after
he pleaded not guilty to murder the
death row records bosses in police
custody accused of intentionally running
over and killing a man and injuring
another
madonna announced she'll perform at this
year's brit 20 years after her last
appearance at the awards she'll be
promoting her latest album rebel heart
which has suffered numerous leaks online
it was announced that harper lee will
publish her second book this summer 55
years after the release of tequila
mockingbird the 88 year old denied she's
been pressured into releasing the novel
entitled go set a watchman mr gray will
see you now and fans of the racial
aspects of the fifty shades of grey
novels won't be disappointed by the big
screen adaptation censors approved the
film without any cuts awarding it an 18
certificate
over the last few years the baftas have
gained prominence in the awards season
calendar drawing some of hollywood's
biggest stars to the red carpet in
london but it's the british talent
that's dominating the acting categories
this year with acclaimed performances
from eddie redmayne benedict cumberbatch
and rosamund pike and across the board
it's the eccentric comedy's birdman and
the grand budapest hotel that have
bowled over bafta voters
many of the hotel's most valued and
distinguished guests came for him i love
you i love you
he's a hollywood clown in the lycra
yes he is but he's going out on that
stage and
it's about risking
respected and validated remember that's
what you told me i got a chance to do
something right do you know why
bye
tied the washing powder the fluorescence
in the washing powder is caught by the
uv light
why do you know
that
mr turing do you know how many have died
because of enigma
no i don't three
while we've been having this
conversation
when you're in a battle against an enemy
so much bigger so much stronger than you
to find out you had a friend
you never knew existed well that's the
best feeling in the world
and the head of bafta amanda berry joins
me now amanda lovely to see you and
you've brought us a bafta i have a very
special bafta i can't tell you who's
going to get this on sunday but somebody
will now some years um there's no
surprises in bafta nominations this year
there seems to be a lot of discussion um
starting off with the grand budapest
hotel leading the way with 11. what's
your take on this year's nominations
well go in budapest hotel is fascinating
because that's a film that came out much
earlier last year and in recent years
the tradition has been that films that
were going to be recognized for awards
needed to come out later in the year so
that's actually thrown the rule book
completely out of the window um and i
don't think anybody expected it i don't
think we saw it coming and on the day we
announced the nominations everybody said
to me what's the biggest surprise for
you and it was grandpa the best hotel
not because it isn't a great film which
it is but the fact that people
remembered it
and the momentum had stayed throughout
many months
um people are also talking about the
snubs mr turner has only got four and
selma has got none i mean how how how do
you what's your take on that it's
interesting isn't it i'm heartbroken
about selma because the reason it hasn't
got any nominations is that people
didn't see it so the film wasn't
delivered in the states until the end of
november then a print has to be shipped
over to the uk
screenings have to be put on dvd
screeners have to be made so before the
bafta voting started there were only
three screenings of the film which meant
that only a matter of hundreds of people
were reached there were six and a half
thousand voting members because of
logistics
that's absolutely what it's all to do
with um and you know just for the film
company they moved as fast as they
possibly could to make everything happen
the one thing that was abundantly clear
in this year's nominations is the young
british talent
ben is it come about eddie redmayne
today but two i mean it's a good crop
this year isn't it it's a fantastic crop
both for you know acting categories but
also the films themselves that you know
we've got two british films in best film
we've got three british actors in the
leading actor category that hasn't
happened since 2007 so it's a great year
to celebrate the british industry you
took over as head of bafta in 2000 and
what's the most significant change or
changes that you've made over that time
is it the date change to precede the
oscars because
the baftas are now so significant in the
awards calendar something that before
you took over wasn't really the case
well it's proof that dreams can come
true so that's really exciting uh when i
joined bafta i joined back in the late
90s as their director of development it
was a time where bafta wanted to make
change it wanted to do more it wanted
its award ceremonies to have a higher
profile and it they had only just
separated the film and television awards
it had taken many years of conversations
because people felt the film awards
wouldn't survive without the television
awards
luckily we've proved them wrong
but the challenge we had was that a lot
of the films we wanted to honour within
the film awards opened much later in the
uk than they did in the us so we
literally had two years of conversations
with the film industry saying how can we
do this how can we make sure the films
we recognize we're doing at the same
time as the globes and the oscars and
then we moved the awards forward
in 2001. you recently made the top 10 of
most powerful women in the arts
congratulations thank you and do you
think there are
good opportunities out there for women
do you think it's a diverse industry
have things got better over the years
hopefully so yeah i have i've never felt
that uh my gender has held me back in
any way at all um and when i look around
me
um you know you see amanda neville at
the bfi there are so many leading women
in arts organizations um and i think
there are opportunities for people and
one of the things we do at bafta is
ensure that we you know support and
recognize new talent
you know not it's not based on gender
it's not doesn't matter you know what
your background is we want to give
people a chance to come through
and you know i really feel the
opportunities are there and we will do
after whatever we can to help people get
them amanda thank you so much for coming
in and for bringing bafta if you want to
leave it here don't worry we will look
after it thank you so much
good luck with the awards
as the co-writer and co-star of gavin
and stacey ruth jones established
herself as one of the leading voices in
british comedy since then she's created
yet another hit series sky one stella
about the everyday trials and
tribulations of a working mum in the
welsh valleys in the new series she may
have found love and happiness but that
doesn't mean life's got any simpler
surprise
oh
my god
and stella star and creator ruth jones
joins me now
the fourth series the fourth i know can
you believe that it's been going so long
it's not your intention at the start not
at all we didn't think that we would do
a second series so it's been incredible
actually uh and it's lovely seeing you
know seeing clips like that and thinking
how far stella has come in her own
personal life and her personal journey
and where she started off in series one
where there was no man in her life and
then she met shawn and then rob came
back in and then she ends up
getting getting together with the next
door neighbor so she's had quite a
journey you co-created it and you you
write bits of it i mean how does that
work starring in it as well does it does
it mean you you kind of go right well
she has to do this and i wanted to do
this and i wanted to say this well um
david pete and myself you know tidy
productions is our company and we make
stella and um we storyline each series
so uh we know what's going to happen
ahead of time and then after we've
worked out what happens in each episode
we then sort of give it to the writers
to put their own spin on it so um yeah
in terms of acting in it because um i'm
also kind of like exact producing i've
kind of always got yeah a lot of plates
spinning and just sort of keeping an eye
on where things are going um but it's
great because i think what it gives you
as an actor is that you know the part
really really well you know what's going
to happen to her you know her backstory
really really well so um so it's a gem
and i love playing stella as an actress
i love playing it and what's really
refreshing about this is is it's quite
gentle humor in some ways as well isn't
it there's quite a lot of outrageous
comedy on the top yeah at the moment and
in the past and it is that what people
say to you that they like that they can
kind of you know watch with their
families and it is it's it is family i
mean it is post watershed but
essentially it is family viewing um
i think people
can feel safe when they watch it um
because
the people in it i mean it's a sort of a
personal thing of mine i guess i think
there's so much horrible stuff going on
in the news that i quite unashamedly go
this show
is you know a show where
there isn't going to be anything nasty
happening and people get up in the
morning and they want to get on with
each other and that's essentially what
it is i think people
we as human beings are naturally very
funny and hopefully we've captured that
in stella there aren't that many female
comics on tv not even on the panel shows
are there i don't
i mean i always hear that said i don't
think it's true i think that's i think
it's quite frankly nonsense of course
there's loads of funny women on telly
and i agree with you that um panel shows
tend to be male dominated but i i've
been on a couple i'm not this i'm not a
good person to have on a panel show
because i i'm not a stand-up and i don't
have that quick wit
um
and i think also this it's a male thing
i'm being incredibly stereotypical now
but i think maybe what happens is that
the men on panel shows are a bit more
kind of they just dive in they go for it
they you know they just want to be heard
whereas the women are a little bit more
um
of a team player i think if i'm honest i
think that's maybe what happens and so
you have to really fight to be heard on
a panel show maybe that's why i don't
know but certainly you don't get many
women on uh you don't get as many women
on panel shows as you do men but in
terms of funny women loads loads out
there uh funny man james corden was one
of the leading men in your life he's now
off in america i know do you have much
contact with him yes yeah yeah um i
he's i mean i haven't i haven't spoken
to him since he's gone i've gone out
there
i know well since he's since he's gone
out this time but i mean the show will
be starting in march i guess won't it so
uh i think he'll be brilliant i think
he'll be absolutely brilliant i think
he's an incredibly talented person james
he's got a lot of different talents he
can do so many different things he's a
brilliant dancer for example you know um
and so i think it'll be lovely and it'll
be refreshing and i think
american audiences would really take to
him and any more governance they see
please say yes no
i i'm amazed that people still ask but
it's a compliment that they too it's a
huge compliment i think also because
it's being shown on a lot of channels
like dave um
and uh
i think
it's it's in people's minds you still
eat it a lot isn't it because i love it
so much exactly and so it's it's lovely
that people love it so much but no
there's we're not bringing it back
we look forward to stella thank you so
much thank you
coming up aardman founders nick park and
peter lord tell me about the sheep
thrills of bringing another creation to
the big screen and we'll be giving you
our tips and predictions for the baftas
the brains behind wallace and gromit at
aardman animations are no strangers to
success with numerous oscars and baftas
to their name but when sean the sheep
made his debut 20 years ago few could
have predicted the sheer scale of his
appeal following his own tv spin-off
he's now starring in his very first
feature film and all without uttering a
word
and executive producers of the film nick
park and peter lorde as well as swan the
sheep join us now lovely to see you both
great to see you what's extraordinary
nick is that sean was only a minor
character in wallace and gromit to start
then he's now your most successful
expert yes i i know i know i mean he
appeared in wallace and gromit's film a
close shave there's this little kind of
hero that helped helps out saves the day
um and we did so many kind of sheep
antics you know break jail breaks and
motorcycle formations i i thought we'd
done everything there was to do with
sheep back then and then then our
colleague richard starzak kind of drove
it into a series and and ran the whole
now five series now
and now a feature film and to many many
countries around the world like yeah
everywhere in the world 180 countries or
something some ridiculous number of
territories you know i've seen pictures
of it being played in the yurt in
mongolia that kind of thing just
everywhere and why did you decide to
have no language in this film no words
does that make it more problematic i
think at first
richard who did the series he he made
the decision that it would be a lot
faster if there was because lip sync you
know the actual manipulation of the
mouths to the words of the actors would
take an awful long it's a lot slower so
to not have any words to say makes the
animation a lot quicker but it did
provide problems for the writers
particularly you know there was a couple
of moments when they would have given
millions just for like one line of
dialogue to explain something just a
couple of moments in the whole thing but
but uh you know i find viewing it you
forget that you're not watching dialogue
you just because everything's completely
understandable isn't it oh absolutely
and this is the first film that you have
made without the backing of a hollywood
studio how has that changed the whole
process is it made it
more difficult or easier
i would say easier
this is done with um studio canal
and you know of course it's lovely for
us it's very pleasing to work with a
european company because we feel like
we're european filmmakers so that's
great um
but i wouldn't say a word against the
big american studios because honestly we
did have a good time with them but
there's a there's a pressure from them
there's a pressure to make a film
that will play in america and that's
that's absolutely in front of their
minds because that's what they think
about and so
you know they always see what we're
doing through that lens and now we don't
have to look through that lens um it's
extraordinary the amount of time and
money that the american studios now
spend in britain isn't it the expertise
we've got over here in terms of
technical animation it's it's really in
the last few years it's been an
extraordinary change hasn't it it has
doesn't we do we train a lot of people
there's star wars and you know the harry
potters have all been made here and i
think the tax breaks have helped that i
believe an awful lot uh so a lot of
personnel are being moved here as well
plus that's great training for for
people in this country as well
um and we've we've always been um you
know animation has always been our thing
in this country um
you know since hardman started in the
80s and it was always advertising with
all the animation talent was in
advertising back then um and now it's
you know
expanding into things like this and
feature films
and you have been nominated for i
believe
10 oscars you've won four what's this
time of year like as an oscar nominee
for us we we work in bristol so we're
not even in the mainstream of the
british film industry
and then you go out there and you're in
the middle of this absolute whirlwind of
showbiz written
as large as possible and it's just
terribly exciting i love it love it love
it the first time we went with nick this
name was um was creature comfortable
creature comforts one little short film
and when they came we came from like we
crept out of a garage you know in
bristol
and we got all rent you know bought
stuff from oxfam and stuff like that and
and went there and and suddenly it's
like everyone turns this massive
spotlight on you and it's incredibly
exciting and fun and it's a good show i
recommend it highly flight pete says
it's just so far from you know you spend
three years or two two or three years in
a darkened studio with a
sweaty
group of people lovely people very
talented
but you spend so long in the dark making
with these little models and then to go
out and be right in the heart of
hollywood i mean i remember the first
times two it was just so
uh strange that leap you know to
suddenly being amongst all these famous
faces
finally i have to ask you and ed
miliband is often uh compared to uh
wallace um some must say some people are
saying that there is a character in
shawn that also looks like him i think
we've got we've got a picture is it was
that intentional
it really wasn't it really really wasn't
no no are you trying to bring down the
leader of the opposition
oh i'm behind the whole way honestly
when when that guy who's the he's the
maitre d of a posh restaurant uh that
the
look alike
and um and he's french and it never
occurred to us for a minute actually
though but i have to say fair play when
you see the stills it doesn't look like
it
has ed miliband ever said anything to
you about wallace um i've never actually
spoke to him
thank you so so much for your time
now one of the most talked about films
this awards season is selma but more so
for its lack of nominations and the
martin luther king biopic is finally
released this weekend
those that have gone before us say
no more
no more
that means protest that means march that
means disturb the peace that means jail
that means risk and that is hard
we will not wait any longer
and entertainment journalist steve
hargrave joins me now steve there's been
an awful lot of talk about this film
what did you think of it yeah i thought
it was excellent absolutely he's
brilliant david that's the weird thing
even watching that clip now of david
yellow the lead actor british actor not
incredibly well known up until this
point he was in spooks he was in spooks
yeah it's such a change it's it's such a
transformation i know you've spoken to
him in real life and he's very english
sounding very sort of theatrical
sounding and that transformation he took
on both in the sound the body language
and the way he portrayed martin luther
king is incredible massive pressure of
course but credit due to ava de verney
the director who put this onto the
screen she's direct i think two films
before comes from a publicity background
but boy has she done wonders with
really getting to the heart of martin
luther king and showing us a side of him
that i guess people haven't seen and
that was their goal that's what they've
always said it's peeling back the
history books really and trying to see
the man within and we see a lot of him
at home in these home scenes so
fantastic performances great film shame
it was snubbed but i think they're okay
with the best picture
it wasn't snub anyway ask david yellow
there
baftas your picks starting off with best
actress who do you think is going to win
well this is as solid a absolute as we
can have i think at the bathrooms this
weekend is that julianne moore is going
to win best actress there i've said it
it better happen now and i'll say i
can't go back extraordinary she plays an
alzheimer's sufferer in still alice
doesn't she yeah amazing performance
incredible film uh a difficult film to
watch but i mean at the heart of it
julianne moore who's done some
incredible work i mean i love shortcuts
magnolia two films that she appears in
which she's amazing and she is an
actress who always goes well out of her
comfort zone and in this one it's quite
a small character-based film and there
she is right at the center of it going
through this incredible battle with
alzheimer's disease and boy does she
just knock it out the parking absolutely
amazing best actor i think will probably
both be agreed on this i think it's
going to be eddie redmayne for the
theory of everything yeah this is the
horse race you've got the two horses
well at the front which is eddie
redmayne and michael keaton for all the
awards and again we've seen them pretty
much battling what the one wins one
award one wins the other bit but eddie's
come out on top really he won the golden
globe which i think is the the biggest
one so far although the last few weeks
birdman has swung back and michael
keaton's won some more of the the sort
of the acting awards from his peers so
it is a little bit up for grabs but
eddie redmayne's transformation to
stephen hawking is another one which is
just truly incredible and remarkable to
watch i couldn't take my eyes off him
watching this film and for someone of
his age his early 30s his need to have
just made that transformation and i
think nailed it so successfully in such
a fantastic film and a british
performance as well of course let's not
forget i think it's his to the taking of
the baftas but michael keaton in birdman
it's such a it's it's it's a comic
performance but it's very very well
wrong
let it be known i love i love birdman i
absolutely
so you didn't i thought it was brilliant
i thought it's beautifully directed i
thoroughly enjoyed it i could watch that
again and again and again so what do you
think is going to win four hood the best
film i have to veer towards boyhood and
i think really from a filmic point of
view what richard linklater did over
those 12 years it's been much talked
about of course returning to the same
act as the same project once every year
was an incredible filmic feat and i
think he's going to be rewarded both at
the baftas and the oscars for that it
might be birdman but as i say birdman is
a is
almost so clever you're sitting on the
fence you're sitting i'm sitting on the
fence but i'm going i'm going boyhood
i'm going boyhood i'm off the fence
we will see what happens we'll play this
sunday and punish me for being wrong
exactly steve thank you so much
and remember we'll be bringing you all
the action live from the bafta red
carpet on sunday on sky news that's all
for now on next week's show celebrating
25 years in the business charlene
spiteri and texas will be playing here
in the studio and we'll hear from oscar
favorite and five-time nominee julianne
moore see you then